well it's important to make sure your
heart health is always a top priority in
Intermountain Healthcare the sponsors of
this segment can help you do just that
joining us today we have Emily Levante
from Intermountain Healthcare with some
helpful tips Emily thank you so much for
being here of course so let's talk about
heart health overall I would imagine
that diet is a very important thing to
keep in mind so how can we be mindful of
that when it comes to our diet
diet is something that's very
particularly important for our heart
health typically you want to stick with
a low-fat diet
high protein
lean meats lots of fruits and vegetables
trying to not add any salt or sugar into
your diet
typically I'll say avoid drinking your
calories avoid those High sugary sodas
and those sorts of things but high in
protein lean protein and lots of fruits
and vegetables protein fruits and
veggies you can't go wrong with that
right and also in addition to that let's
talk about working out and exercise and
cardio activities how often should you
be doing that a week to maintain a
healthy and happy heart so the American
Heart Association recommends either 75
minutes of vigorous intensity activity a
week kind of spaced out throughout the
week or 150 minutes of moderate
intensity activity space throughout the
week so however you really divide that
up they do recommend it's spacing it out
instead of doing the full thing all in
one day and then waiting till the next
week to exercise so
um yeah just good to get your body
moving when you can that's right that's
right and let's talk about the seniors
and if it's any different for them when
it comes to diet exercise or even you
know keeping their cholesterol in mind
what should they think about when it
comes to their heart health so seniors
one thing I would one thing that I would
say is that our seniors really do need
to be paying attention to their
cholesterol so for instance if if they
have any heart disease they need to eat
a low cholesterol diet if they have
diabetes they need to make sure that
their sugars are under good control
that they're taking their Statin
cholesterol medication if they've been
prescribed one it's really all about
limiting their risk factors for future
heart attack and stroke so age in and of
itself is a risk factor so keeping the
cholesterol under control is really
really important keeping diabetes under
control and blood pressure under
controller really important also the
thing is
limiting the amount of caffeine in our
patients are elderly or senior patients
those that are smokers that's
particularly difficult for those
patients to stop smoking because it's
been a habit for likely a long time yeah
well a lot of really helpful things to
keep in mind and just for all of us to
keep it top of Mind in our day-to-day
activity so thank you so much for
breaking this all down for us and if you
guys want more information all the
information is on your screen and thank
you again to Intermountain Healthcare
for sponsoring the segment for more
information visit
intermountainhealthcare.org forward
slash Nevada we'll be right back
[Music]